go to the big board with with our own
bill hammer tonight bill a lot going on
what's uh the latest indeed uh sean good
evening to you stunning report by trey
right now try and zero in a little bit
on what trey was describing there uh
three stories two of them in the south
and then we'll get to keeve in the
capital city and the north is the third
story this is the town of mario paul
that trey was just talking about it has
been
they've been pounded for three days sean
and some of the video here that we've
seen on the inside of the city here uh
taken fire from the from the sea of
assaf and taking fire from the land as
well you know what why is that ask
yourself why is this so important to the
russian army well you think about you
know putin went into this donbass region
here eight years ago and he took half of
it and if the russian military that came
out of crimea about nine days ago on a
bee line up in mario paul if they can
secure this city you can now see the
land bridge it starts to come down
uh and in a moment here almost forms
like a crescent there at the bottom part
of the country
that's one aspect of this story here the
other one is to the left here past the
city of kirsan that fell
two days ago as the first city in the
country that fell
and russian forces have moved toward
microlave as well keep that city in mind
city of 450 000 i'll explain why in a
moment here but if they're able to
take the southeastern portion and make
this link with the southwest uh they'll
go after the city of odessa and that
talk about a refugee issue there the
million people that live in odessa and
that would be the next target along the
line after a mica leaf here
story number two is the nuclear
situation here and shauna was on with
you last night when uh we were talking
about this area right here where we hit
the fire nearby well there was a report
a bit earlier today that the russian
forces are moving on this area michael
aven and this town too there is another
large nuclear facility now we know the
problems we have with the russian fire
when they surrounded this facility uh
and in the previous town which is the
largest nuclear facility in all of
europe uh so now you could have another
situation here where you're starting to
question you know the the safety and the
security of uh the second nuclear plant
here uh this is where we were last night
sean and you know hodar here
you have six different nuclear reactors
five of them were in operation one was
under construction the good news and all
of this if the if you can even say that
the good news that we found is that the
fire was about 1200 feet away from the
reactor itself and might have saved an
enormous disaster of of immense
proportions here
just 24 hours ago let's pop on over here
to the north john i know you had
questions in a moment ago about to jen
about
what's happening with this convoy it is
still pretty much stuck where it is
has been for the past several days
but the forces here are outlined in this
red area here
and sean i i know our viewers some of
them have seen these pictures online i
know you have as well and i've seen them
for the past week
some of these towns in this red portion
here have been absolutely annihilated
and i i bring that up because here's the
capital city of kiev and we believe that
still the incentive is to go ahead and
surround the city
with that convoy that stretches roughly
right around this area and
is holding there at the airport we
believe eventually this convoy is going
to find a way to inch its way further
south then eventually take all that
military hardware and surround the city
and if if they do in key with a city of
3 million which they've done in other
parts of this country you just imagine
the devastation there and the loss of
human life i it's staggering really when
you think about it here and
they have not done i want to make this
clear they have not gotten to this point
yet
they're really pretty much right about
here at the airport and then some
reports from jack keane's group a bit
earlier today the generals are reporting
that it appeared that as as if the
ukrainian army had had pushed the
russian army further west
from the city let me maybe they go ahead
sean here go you know
to hear those words towns annihilated is
is beyond chilling
you've seen them right you've seen the
pictures i've seen the pictures all
right so they've been trapped there
uh jennifer mentioned that a bridge had
been blown out uh are they able to cross
where is that bridge in relation to
where the convoy is my my feeling has
been that if the convoy makes it too
keen
with with that many munitions and tanks
and
and everything else that they have with
them and fuel etc and missiles that this
could be a massacre in kiev the capital
city so stopping that convoy from ever
arriving in kiev to me would be a top
priority so
what is the status what's holding him up
i'll give you the best
approximate length here that i can let's
say this is the city center of kiev okay
sean
uh the airport on on a b line is about
20 miles
but the convoy
is stopped about 16 miles from the city
center and and that bridge that you're
talking about in fact coming up we're
going to work for laura at 10 o'clock
tonight but we're going to talk to
somebody who was just in that area where
that bridge is located it's about this
area right here sean i i wish i could
push in and show you a little more
specifics but that's about the area
where it is point being a lot of your
action is in this part of the city okay
so far and it again just keep this in
mind if we get a few days from now or
even a week or even two weeks from now
this is still the intent we believe on
behalf of the russian army and the
reason why i make that point sean is
because the city of car key russian
speaking 1.5 million 20 miles just
across the border from russia here this
city has been hammered
just like all the other areas that i was
explaining a moment ago and based on the
reporting we're getting it's surrounded
but it has not fallen so they're still
hanging on in the city of kharkiv which
is
if i could just go forward just one time
here
um capital city kevi is here karkiva is
over here and they're they're hanging on
for now but you have to wonder what is
left of that city and frankly there's
not much i'll show you one more thing
here sean just to complete the story 1.2
million refugees and that number is
going to change every day and
unfortunately it's only going to go
higher from here sean all right bill
hammer very informative thank you hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else